[Music]
only trust thyself and another shall not
betray
Thee the saddest thing about betrayal is
that it never comes from your
[Music]
enemies they talk of a man betraying his
country his friends his sweetheart there
must be a moral Bond first all a man can
betray is his conscience
when someone betrays you it is a
reflection of their character not
yours silence is a true friend who never
[Music]
betrays those who don't know the value
of loyalty can never appreciate the cost
of
betrayal sometimes instead of being Hur
you should look at betrayal as a gift it
makes it that much easier to sweep it up
and toss it out with the rest of the
trash betrayal can be extremely painful
but it's up to you how much that pain
damages you
permanently life is not about who's real
to your face it's about who's real
behind your
back
when no one you know tells the truth you
learn to see under the
surface there is always a lesson to
learn in every
[Music]
betrayal betraying someone once can be a
mistake betraying someone twice is a
[Music]
choice the knives of betrayal and drama
cut deep in been hurt but they also trim
away the nonsense and reveal your true
[Music]
friends for there to be betrayal there
would have to have been trust
[Music]
first breaking someone's trust is like
crumpling up a perfect piece of paper
you can smooth it over but it's never
going to be the same
again some people are willing to betray
years of friendship just to get a little
bit of the
spotlight if you do not express your own
ideas if you do not listen to your own
being you will have betrayed
yourself the worst mistake a man can
make is to betray a woman who actually
supported him when he was going through
the worst time of his
life betrayal is common for men with no
[Music]
conscience faithful are the wounds of a
friend but the kisses of an enemy are
[Music]
deceitful betray a friend and you'll
often find you have ruined
[Music]
yourself the Betrayal of trust carries a
heavy
taboo
love comes to those who still hope after
disappointment who still believe after
betrayal and who still love after
they've been
hurt even the people who betray you are
part of the
[Music]
plan the real betrayal is forgetting
yourself when you care about someone you
can't just turn that off because you
learn they betrayed
you it is more shameful to distrust our
friends than to be deceived by
[Music]
them some of the most poisonous people
come disguised as
friends the worst kind of hurt is
betrayal because it means that someone
will be willing to hurt you just to make
themselves feel
better
it is easier to forgive an enemy than to
forgive a
[Music]
friend betrayal doesn't only break your
heart but also darkens your
soul keep talking about me behind my
back and watch God keep blessing me in
front of your
[Music]
face Love and Marriage are wonderful
Arenas in which to place a
character there is nothing worse than
betraying
[Music]
yourself betrayal is so emotionally
charged because the act of betrayal
violates a couple's core agreement the
promise to care for each other and keep
each other
safe beware the person who stabs you and
then tells the world they're
bleeding
they can betray me but I choose not to
betray my peace of
[Music]
mind most friendship is figing most love
mere
Folly betray a friend and you'll often
find you have ruined
yourself I'm mature enough to forgive
you but I'm not dumb enough to trust you
again
sometimes the person you take a bullet
for is pulling the
trigger there's no black and no white
just Shades of Gray but small betrayals
lead to bigger ones and morality is
eroded betrayal is never easy to handle
and there is no right way to accept
it
if you're betrayed release
disappointment at once that way
bitterness has no time to take
root an honest enemy is better than a
false friend when a doubt pay more
attention to what people do and less
attention to what they
[Music]
say
stab the body and it heals injure the
heart and the wound lasts a
[Music]
lifetime nothing hurts more than being
disappointed by the one person you
thought would never hurt
you love love never betrays people
[Music]
do forgive yourself for the blindness
that placed you in the path of those who
betrayed you sometimes a good heart
can't see the
bad don't trust a wife who doesn't trust
[Music]
you
the one who forgave the Betrayal of his
wife soon will realize she is no longer
his
[Music]
wife